موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم جددت القوات
التركيه قصف مواقع ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه شمال شرقي سوريا وقد اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع التركيه توحيده 14 عنصر من
مسلحي حزب العمال الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه
الشعب الكرديه اعتذالك في وقتنا اعلن فيه
قائم ومقام كرمش التركيه تعطيل المدارس في
عمومه انحاء القضاء لمده يومين اعتبارا من
امس الاثنين
قالت مصادر الرسميه للجزيره
لتلبيه مطالب تركيا شمال سوريا كبديل عن
العمليه العسكريه واعطت انقرا مهله زماليه
لتلبيه شروطها والا فسيكون البديل عمليه
عسكريه تشمل المناطق المذكوره
قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغاني ان
بلاده لن تستاذن اي احد لاتخاذ خطوات
لحمايه امل اراضيها لا في ثاني الا ان
العمليات العسكريه ستتواصل حتى القضاء على
اخر عنصر ارهابي حسب وصفه وادعى اردوغان
لانهاء ما سماها لعبه تخفي امتدادات حزب
العمال الكردستاني باسماء مختلفه تحت ستار
الحرب على تنظيم الدوله
طلبت بيان علي الرئيسه المشتركه لما يعرف
بمكتب الدفاع في الاداره الذاتيه لشمال
وشرق سوريا الدولتين الضاميتين ليخفي
اطلاق النار الولايات المتحده وروسيا
بتحديد موقف واضح من الهجمات
اعلنت الشرطه الصوماليه انتهاء عمليه فندق
فيلا روز واضافت ان 15 عمر شخصا قتلوا
بينهم المهاجمون سته و رجل امن صومالي
بينما اصيب خمسه من رجال الامن في الهجوم
الذي جنته حركه الشباب على الفندق الواقعي
قرب القصر الرئاسي في العاصمه مقديشو
وطالب الرئيس الصومالي وحسن الشيخ محمود
المجتمع الدوليه بالوقوف الى جانب حكومه
بلاده من اجل هزيمه ما وصفه بالارهاب وقال
ان بلاده في حرب العالميه مع الارهاب الذي
يهدد العالم اجمع حسب تعبيره
قال الرئيس دونالدز الموالي لروسيا دينيس
بوسلين ان القوات الاوكرانيه تنقل جنود من
خرطوم الى دونيتك معظمهم من جنود الاحتياط
في المقابل قال الجيش الاوكراني انه يجري
تجهيز قطارات لاجلاء المدنيين من سكان
خرسون الى مقاطعه
خمننسكي غربيه البلاد بسبب اشتداد القصف
الروسي
قالت السلطات الماليه لروسيا اين اكثر من
700 جنديا من القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه
تتمركز في محيطيه ويتم اعدادهم اقتحام
المحطه النوويه في المقاطعه هذا هو نفى
المتحدث باسم الكربلائي سكوف ما يروجوا من
معلومات عن انسحاب روسي
وقال ديسكو في انه ليست هناك حاجه للبحث
عن مؤشرات غير موجوده بخصوص امكانيه
الانسحاب من المحطه
اعلنت سلطاته مدينه اوروتشي عاصمه مقاطعه
تشينجيا شمال غربيه الصين تخفيفه اجراءات
الاغلاق المتعلقه بمكافحه فيروس كورونا
تاتي الخطوه بعد احتجاجات شعبيه في مدن
صينيه مختلفه على سياسات الاغلاق المستمره
منذ ظهور الفايروس قبل نحو ثلاث سنوات في
مدينه وهران حتى المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده ستيفاندوجيريك
الحكومه الصينيه على احترام معايير حقوق
الانسان الدوليه من جهه اعتبر المتحدث
باسم مجلس الامن القومي التابعي للبيت
الابيض ان من حق الناس التظاهر في اي مكان
من العالم بما في ذلك الصين
كتاب موجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]